[Applause]
it's time to talk parenting trends and
understanding kids as
i momsplain it all one of the biggest
trade-offs of parenthood at least in the
first few years is
sleep if you have young kids there's a
good chance you haven't had a good night
of sleep since before
they were born a new survey of parents
with kids under
age 18 and under found that 46 say that
their kids are the main reason that they
struggle to sleep and 39
say that if their kids aren't sleeping
they can't get any sleep
the survey also looked into the things
that kids do to
invade their parents precious sleep time
and the top responses
were getting into their parents bed at
night and using devices with screens
like playing video games being on
tablets and watching tv
other things kids do to keep their
parents up include playing with their
toys
reading books crying hanging out late
with their friends and
homework also should women give up their
names
when they get married 72 percent of
adults say
yes a new survey from the atlantic says
that the majority of adults believe that
a woman should change her maiden name
and half of those who responded said
they believe
that it should be a legal requirement
but when it comes to men
it is a different story less than three
percent of men
take their wife's last name and finally
let's talk
tick-tock trends the where'd all the
time go challenge is huge right now
it's where the user takes an old picture
of them as a child and then uses the
reverse
shape-shifting filter to transform into
their current day self
here are some examples the videos are
played to the song
where'd all the time go by dr dog and
many people
are finding it to be a very emotional
experience
so of course i had to give it a try
oh time flies give it a try if you want
to be a little sad
and now you've had a mom's plating over
to you it's adorable